präsident mit mir gemeinsam und laut die
namen derjenigen die zu dieser stadt
gehörten und heute nicht mehr bei uns
sein können
ferhat in war
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lasst uns den rassisten in diesem land
zeigen wir halten zusammen und wir
werden uns verteidigen
es kann nicht sein dass in dieser
gesellschaft gerade menschen angst haben
aus ihrer haus raus zu gehen weil sie
schwarze haare
aber sie kopftuch tragen weil sie
übertreffen es kann nicht wahr sein dass
menschen angst in ihren leben an dieser
gesellschaft
[Musik]
neunzehnter februar 2020 ein rechts
terrorist erschießt den hanau gezielt
menschen ausländischer herkunft mit zwei
voll geladenen waffen zu tobias ehrlos
betritt die bar la botte wo er vier
schüsse auf den mann hinter der theke
feiert sein opfer ist kilian will kopf
ein 33-jähriger gebürtige bulgare und
familienvater anschließend läuft tobias
er auf die straße wo er zufällig auf
partys oder schuld trifft
er schießt den 34 jährigen der erst vor
kurzem nach hanau gezogen war
in der shisha bar midnight tötet er dann
den besitzer bis 29 jahre alt
als tobias er wieder auf die straße
läuft wird er von willi viorel paaren
beobachtet der in seinem auto sitzt und
zurück fährt obwohl sein wagen
geschossen wird verfolgt der 22 jährige
willi den terroristen bis zum zweiten
tatort in hanau kesselstadt dort wird
der junge mann später in seinem auto
erschossen aufgefunden
nach diesem mord betritt der rechts
terrorist einen kiosk und die
benachbarte arena war erschießt fünf
weitere menschen für ein gehabt gesehen
50 leute liegen auf dem boden zwei
hinter der tg 2 also alles total blutbad
waren unter den opfern der 37 jährige
gökhan gültig hin
die alleinerziehende mutter mercedes
kierpiec hansa-coach 22 jahre alt der
21-jährige zeitmesser haschemi
und fährt hat unwahr der 23 jahre alt
wurde
seine mutter ist sehr viel themis
unwahre kann oft nicht begreifen dass
ihr sohn ermordet wurde
fell hat war ihr ältestes von vier
kindern so stolz war sie auf ihn fährt
hat hatte gerade seine ausbildung zum
heizungstechniker beendet und war voller
zukunftspläne ich akzeptiere ganz nett
gar nichts für mich
lebt weiter weil ich habe angst von
diesem gedanken
also gibt immer geholfen zum andere
kinder die sagen selber zu mir das sogar
wenn er selber probleme hat es mal die
andere probleme jahr war wichtig immer
bereit er war ja immer bereits vom
andere freunde
sehr viel erzählt uns dass sie voller
angst ist denn der todeszeitpunkt von
fährt hat war erst um 13
rund fünf stunden nach den schüssen in
dem kiosk neben der arena war
was war in der zwischenzeit hat hat
gelitten hat sich jemand um ihn
gekümmert
[Musik]
das kann gar nicht sein das tut ja
wählen ein monate dachte ich mein sohn
im krankenhaus gestohlen
insgesamt fühlt sich sehr bild emission
war von den ermittlungsbehörden schlecht
informiert und der polizeieinsatz in
dieser nacht am 19 februar wirft viele
fragen auf
es gibt ein video der überwachungskamera
in dem kiosk her hat starb
etwa um 22 uhr fallen hier die ersten
schüsse ca 14 minuten später betritt der
erste polizist ikiosk zwei minuten
danach kommen die ersten sanitäter rein
erste auffälligkeit die sanitäter
untersuchen zu diesem zeitpunkt nicht
alle opfer sie schauen nach den am boden
liegenden mercedes kierpiec und göttern
gültekin nicht aber nach ferhat unwahr
der hinter der theke liegt der
23-jährige wird weder von den
rettungskräften noch von der polizei
beachtet
die uhr der überwachungskamera geht
sieben minuten nach um circa 22 uhr 18
also vier minuten später steigt ein
polizist über den am boden liegenden
fährt hat weiterhin ohne ihn zu beachten
und schließt ein rollo etwa zwei minuten
danach noch einmal
der polizist steigt überfährt hat guckt
sogar zu ihm runter und spannt dann
einen schirm auf aus dem video lässt
sich schließen
wer hat wird erst zehn minuten nachdem
der erste polizist in kiosk betreten hat
und 24 minuten nach den ersten schüssen
von rettungskräften und polizei zum
ersten mal beachtet und untersucht
brisant sind diese erkenntnisse auch
weil der offizielle todeszeitpunkt bei
fährt hat unwahr
laut sterbeurkunde 13 war
[Musik]
auf der überwachungskamera ist auch zu
sehen dass sich verhalten doch hinter
die theke schleppt nachdem er von dem
rechts terroristen geschossen wurde
seine mutter sehr viel weiß aus den
ermittlungen was er da sagte ich bin
immer in diesem moment mit ihm zusammen
er sagt zwei wollte ich will nrw
weiterleben natürlich erkennt ihn noch
weiter meldet sich retten verstecken
oder was weiß ich von dort dieser ort
weggehen aber keine cook nach ihm um das
ist ja so schwer für mich
ich bin immer mit ihm in diesem moment
dass ich will ja die verantwortliche
polizei in südosthessen will uns zu
diesem sachverhalt nichts sagen
er wird treffe unmittelbar den
ermittlungskomplex den die
generalbundesanwaltschaft übernommen
habe und die hat ihre
ermittlungsergebnisse noch nicht
vorgestellt
[Musik]
willi viorel paarungen wurde 22 jahre
alt er sei so glücklich gewesen sagen
seine eltern hatte eine freundin und
eine gute arbeit in einer kurierfirma
julia und nicholas cooper und sind immer
noch tief traurig sie sind gerade aus
rumänien zurück gekommen
die beiden haben dort in den letzten
monaten für willi eine monumentale
grabstätte errichtet und ihn in der
kirche mit großen schmerzen
verabschiedet ist kaputt ist auch wie
stein und immer noch immer noch julia
wartet das wird nach hause kommen ich
denke immer an unseren willi ich kann
immer noch nicht glauben dass er nicht
mehr da ist
es geht mir sehr schlecht willi war ihr
einziges kind
er sei so glücklich gewesen mit seiner
freundin mit der er eine familie gründen
wollte
und auch mit seinen eltern hat er immer
viel unternommen
julia und nicholas cooper lebt mit willi
zusammen
in diese wohnung sind die beiden wenige
wochen nach seinem tod gezogen weg auch
von hanau
[Musik]
wir gucken ganzen tag auf diesem video
of company das alles was wir haben jetzt
drei monate nach der tat trafen wir
julia und nicolas copa und zum ersten
mal niculescu zeigt uns das handy von
willi dass sie am vortag von der polizei
zurück bekommen hatten willi hatte in
der tatnacht mehrfach versucht die
polizei zu erreichen
hinter verfolgt hat viel mark
telefoniert zum polizei war und keine
antwort von polizei und das verständnis
keiner hatte den beiden damals gesagt
dass willi versucht hatte die polizei zu
erreichen und den täter zu stoppen
sie selbst haben es recherchiert und die
tatnacht rekonstruiert im mai zeigten
sie uns auch das auto von willi dass sie
kurz vorher von der polizei zurück
bekommen hatten mit den einschusslöchern
aus der tatnacht
[Musik]
insgesamt feuerte der rechts terrorist
sieben schüsse auf willi ab
schulter willi hatte den täter verfolgt
der bemerkte ihn und tötete ihn mit
einem kopfschuss durch die
windschutzscheibe in einem video einer
überwachungskamera vom tattag ist oben
rechts willis auto zu sehen
tobias er rennt an ihm vorbei willi
fährt mit seinem auto zurück nimmt die
verfolgung auf bis zum zweiten tatort im
hanauer stadtteil kesselstadt dort wird
willi später von der polizei tot in
seinem auto gefunden
seine eltern erfuhren am nächsten mittag
dass ihr sohn ermordet worden war
warum ist das passiert wie es passiert
heute will uns die polizei kein
interview geben anders als noch im mai
2020 drei monate nach der tat
wir sprachen mit polizeihauptkommissar
henry faltin hat versucht viermal die
polizei an zurück warum hat die tat
reagiert
in der nacht haben sehr viele menschen
angerufen das heißt wir haben die
information über den sachverhalt
bekommen und das ist auch wichtig
besonders wichtig dass wir eingeladen
bekommen aber es wird technisch einfach
gar nicht machbar sein dass alle
menschen durch kommen und so erklärt
sich auch dass viele anrufen und die
polizei da nicht erreicht haben und ist
aber war willi beruhen so dass er ja
einer der ersten maler können gar nicht
so viele anrufe eingegangen sein
weil das ja erst passiert ist und hier
kann es dann sein dass man eben in der
schleife eben gerade besetzt hat ist
dann deswegen tragisch weil jetzt klar
ist dass willy baron nicht in einer
shisha bar ermordet wurde sondern den
täter verfolgt hat da versucht hat die
polizei zu erreichen ist das jetzt teil
der ermittlungen auch dass man sagt
eventuell hätte er überleben eventuell
hätte man weitere morde verhindern
können alles was dazu beiträgt den
gesamt sachverhalt zu erklären wird
natürlich teil der ermittlungen auf
werden
es waren vor allem niculescu und julia
parodie die ermittlungen im fall ihres
sohnes willi vorangetrieben haben
ein langer kampf um gerechtigkeit im
hessischen landtag wollten sie ihre
fragen gemeinsam mit anderen angehörigen
auch an die politiker richten
am ende waren sie aber enttäuscht ich
bin nicht zufrieden zu fliegen
wir haben keine information was passiert
in diesen 8 mittlerweile weiß man was
passiert ist in dieser nacht als willi
parolen die polizei nicht erreichen
konnte auf der polizeiwache waren nur
zwei leitungen für notrufe
freigeschaltet und nur ein beamter vor
ort um sie anzunehmen
außerdem wurden die notrufe hier nicht
automatisch an eine zentrale leitstelle
weitergeleitet was bei überbelastung in
anderen polizeistellen üblich ist
unterbesetzung und ein veraltetes
notrufsystem haben also dazu geführt
dass willis anrufe und auch die anderer
zeugen in der tatnacht nicht ankommen
der hessische innenminister peter beuth
räumte erst vor kurzem fehler ein und
will jetzt etwas ändern um
sicherzustellen dass mehr notrufe in
hanau bei einer herausragenden
polizeilichen lage entgegen genommen
werden können wurde ein weiter leitungs
konzept entwickelt dass noch in diesem
monat fertig gestellt werden soll
für willi viorel palm kommt das zu spät
der 22-jährige hat sieben monate nach
seinem tod die anerkennung für sein
mutiges verhalten bekommen auch die
angehörigen zollen willi respekt als er
am tag der zivilcourage seine eigene
gedenkstätte hält alle sind sich einig
willi viorel paarung ist ein held im
grunde hat willi [ __ ] l nahezu alles
richtig gemacht ist eine zutiefst
tragische feststellung es nämlich nicht
einfach nur auf eigene faust und ich
krieg das schon irgendwie in den griff
hinterher
da die verfolgung aufgenommen aber hat
auch versucht hilfe zu holen
willi viorel paar und hat uns gezeigt
was zivilcourage ist julia und nicholas
cooper und sind stolz dass ihr sohn die
ehrung bekommen hat die er verdient hat
und für die sie so lange gekämpft haben
aber die beiden sind auch sehr traurig
mein kopf sagt war mutig und hat also
ein hält aber unterschätzt sagt wir
brauchen kein härchen weg nach hause
willi war mutig und selbstlos
aber wenn er die polizei in dieser nacht
erreicht hätte hätte die mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit davon abgeraten den
gefährlichen bewaffneten täter zu
verfolgen
katholisch ist schuld die polizei wenn
die notruf nicht am worte wie er wollte
gott das macht mich kaputt das mag mich
kaputt wenn willi den notruf erreicht
hätte würde er heute noch leben
kim hatte das glück zu überleben
die 25 jährige war in der tatnacht in
dem kiosk in kesselstadt und kurz
rausgegangen weil sie im vierten monat
schwanger und ihr schlecht geworden war
da beobachtete kim auf dem parkplatz wie
tobias er will ihn in seinem auto
erschossen später im kiosk auffährt hat
unbekannt gültekin und mercedes kierpiec
mercedes war eine ihrer besten
freundinnen
kim hat tobias er direkt in die augen
geschaut verstört einfach verstört er
hat die waffe zitternd hochgehoben und
währenddessen habe ich mich denn ich
habe gedacht ich bin jetzt tot weil ich
habe ich hab jetzt erst die schüsse
gehört hatten als erstes gesehen und ich
habe nur noch meine hände dann nur noch
wirklich so gemacht und bin einfach da
nur noch getoppt
ich hab mich nur noch geduckt und ich
hab gedacht okay jetzt bin ich tot tim
weiß dass sie großes glück gehabt hat
sie leidet immer noch unter dem was sie
am 19 februar erlebt hat wird auch
psychologisch betreut
die 25-jährige belastetes sehr ihr
lebensgefährte fabio weiß dass dass sie
ihre freunde nicht rechtzeitig
wahrnehmen konnte
währenddessen ist nicht mal den satz
beendet habe es halt schon reingekommen
und hat dann alle vor mir hat erschossen
der täter ist dann in die arena rhein
gelaufen und hat dann dort weiter
ermordet und in dem zeitraum wo er halt
in der arena war hab ich halt die flucht
genommen bin halt aus dem fenster
gesprungen und bin halt auch wirklich
blöd gefallen auch auf meinen bauch auf
die knie ich bin dann einfach weiter
gerannt
das ist das schönste
das ist passiert ist ja gerade das vieh
verloren freunde die man verloren hat
aber umso kleiner gut schätzen
eigentlich was für ein glück die beiden
hatten und dass hier gibt da ein
bisschen kraft ihre freundin mercedes
hatte dieses glück nicht
eine lebenslustige junge frau sei die
gewesen die immer alle mitgerissen haben
sie werden sie nie vergessen
[Musik]
der tatort in kesselstadt wirft noch
weitere fragen auf
dabei geht es auch um den notausgang in
der arena war denn der tat nacht
verschlossen war
mit fatalen folgen vitamine man hat den
anschlag am 19 februar auch überlebt er
war damals mit seinen freunden in der
arena war als die schüsse fielen und hat
viele von ihnen sterben sehen
peter selbst wurde von keiner einzigen
kugel getroffen
meine erklärung ist nur was der liebe
herr mich dann im moment um das kann es
mir ist ehrlich gesagt nicht erklärt
peter z uns dass sie damals die schüsse
auf dem parkplatz gehört hätten
tobias er hatte gerade beliebt in seinem
auto in ordnung
später im kiosk neben der arena war auch
werth hat ungültig ihn und mercedes
kipper später erinnert sich an kim die
kurz rausgegangen war und ein alarm
schlug ihm kam herein und hat gerufen da
ist jemand mit einer waffe da kommt
jetzt rein und daraufhin sind wir halten
nicht zum notausgang gegangen weil wir
eben wussten dass der notausgang zu ist
und wir dort einfach ohne barriere vor
dem täter in seiner schusslinie gewesen
werden also haben wir uns entschieden
nach hinten zum tresen zu gehen dann
aber auch noch eine tür und die tiere
aber auch abgeschlossen
und da machen wir in der sackgasse in
der sackgasse weil die notausgangstür
auf der rückseite der bar versperrt war
deswegen ermittelt jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft hanau zeugen sagen
der notausgang sei schon seit langem
verschlossen gewesen weil das ein deal
des barbesitzers mit der polizei gewesen
sei um razzien zu erleichtern
stimmt das ein interview sagt uns die
polizei auch dazu ab schriftlich
bestreitet sie den vorwurf durch die
polizei er geht niemals eine weisung
oder aufforderung notausgänge zu
verschließen oder auf andere weise zu
versperren
im gegenteil werden weil erkennen
derartiger verstöße umgehend die
zuständigen fachdienststellen von uns
informiert umgehend informiert das
stimmt nicht
nach zdf-informationen war schon im
tatort bericht vom februar 2020
bezüglich des notausgangs in der arena
bar von verschlossenen türen die rede
konsequenzen gab es keine und die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt jetzt auch
nur weil angehörige der opfer anzeige
erstattet haben
es gibt mindestens 16 zeugen die
ausgesagt haben
dazu gehört auch nicht denn nicht
erkannt werden will der 24-jährige war
oft mit hansa coach und seinem bruder in
der arena bar und hat viele razzien
erlebt
ich schätze mal ist es sind nie
irgendwie in not ausgänge versperrt oder
davor gelaufen die fluchtwege die
wussten ganz genau wenn die hier
reinkommen wir sind eingekesselt es
heißt doch keiner bewegung keiner
glücklich weil wir es halt wussten und
dies auch wussten genau so wie wir sie
selbst hätten nichts zu den
verschlossenen notausgängen gesagt weil
sie keinen ärger haben wollten
das erzählt uns auch paco er habe 2017
in der arena war schwarz gearbeitet und
angst um seinen job gehabt deswegen habe
auch er geschrieben
der notausgang seien definitiv schon
damals verschlossen gewesen sagt er und
die polizei habe das gewusst
das habe er gleich am anfang bei einer
razzia gemerkt der junge wollte durch
den notausgang dabei der vermieter auch
dann offen ist das gerade polizist ganz
normal
er muss gewusst haben dass er nun auch
ganz spanien geschnappt
werber für mich auch schon auf ein jahr
lang hat parcours und arena bar
gearbeitet und in dieser zeit immer
wieder bei razzien den eindruck gewonnen
dass die polizei von dem verschlossenen
notausgang wusste
die staatsanwaltschaft will sich zu den
ermittlungen nicht äußern
fest steht die angehörigen der opfer
erwarten auch darauf so schnell wie
möglich antworten wer ist für den
verschlossenen notausgang in der arena
war verantwortlich der für zeitmesser
haschemi und hamza kurtovic zur
todesfalle wurde seinen vater armin
kurtovic macht das traurig und wütend
zugleich hätte seinen sohn hamza
überleben können wenn der notausgang
nicht verschlossen gewesen wäre
in dem video der überwachungskamera in
der arena ist auch hansa zu sehen
armin und seine frau diana wollen sich
das niemals anschauen aber ihr anwalt
hat ihnen davon erzählt man sieht wie
man sohn versucht eine tür vom lager
aufzumachen
die abgeschlossen waren also die zeit
hatten die und das lässt mir keine ruhe
die leute dieses video gesehen haben die
überlebenden da drin
die sagen alle dasselbe wir haben die
schüsse auf dem parkplatz gehört
die haben den täter rein kommen sind
wenn er den kiosk
das hat 19 kunden gedauert im kiosk und
alle sagen ein stimmt wir sind nicht zum
notausgang gegangen weil wir wussten
dass er abgeschlossen ist beim alten
zeugen haben die sich geweigert hätten
die zeugenaussagen aufzunehmen weil sie
sagen ist es irrelevant wenn man das sei
der tat macht weiß wenn man es nicht in
die zeugenaussagen aufnehmen will
dann weiß ich nicht wer da was zu
verheimlichen hat und warum für wen das
was sie erleiden müssten sagen diane und
damir kurtovic wünschten sie niemandem
ihr sohn hamza hatte eine ausbildung zum
fachlageristen gemacht und erst drei
wochen vor seinem tod einen neuen job
angefangen mit dem er sehr glücklich
gewesen sei ein höflicher hilfsbereiter
junger der es geliebt habe mit seinen
freunden auszugehen
hamza coach wurde 22 jahre alt seine
familie leidet bis heute darunter dass
sie sich nicht würdig von hamza
verabschieden konnte erst am morgen nach
der tat hätten sie erfahren dass hamza
seinen verletzungen erlegen sei und halb
sie erst nicht geschafft er ist tot und
wir wissen nicht wo er ist
am nächsten tag haben sie die obduktion
gemacht ohne mit uns zu reden kein
mensch hat uns irgendwas gefragt und
dann komme ich dahin oder als ich mir
das angesehen hat wie sie hinzu
gerichtet haben
und im nachhinein behaupten die ja mit
uns geredet
das ist eine lüge das stimmt nicht meine
frau hat geweint hat die angefleht ihn
zu sehen nein es geht nicht
spurensicherung
die polizei teilt und schriftlich dazu
nur folgendes mit die
strafprozessordnung sieht keine pflicht
zu einer anhörung der angehörigen eines
todesopfers vor dessen obduktion vor
wenn hierdurch der untersuchungs zweck
gefährdet würde
in hanau erinnern ein jahr nach dem
terror viele orte an die neun jungen
menschen die von einem rassisten getötet
wurden
auch im benachbarten frankfurt am main
unter der friedensbrücke keiner soll sie
vergessen
[Musik]
die angehörigen sind zusammengewachsen
hatten sich immer wieder zu
demonstrationen und gedenken wie hier
auf dem hanauer friedensplatz sechs
monate nach dem terror
[Musik]
sie alle haben es satt dass immer von
einzelfällen gesprochen werde
wenn rechtsradikale in diesem land
morgen kann es sein dass ein täter mit
einer solchen vorgeschichte überhaupt
legal waffen besitzen kann diesen
wertvollen leben sollen nicht umsonst
verloren sein
bei einer gesellschaft mit max und
weniger hass an jedem 19 im monat kommen
sie zusammen um an die getöteten zu
erinnern wie hier auf dem friedhof in
hanau wo fährt hat ungarn hansa-coach
und zeitmesser haschemi begraben liegen
[Musik]
oder wie hier auf dem hanauer marktplatz
mir salam haschemi ist gekommen
der vater von zeitmesser genauso wie
armin kurtovic und serpil teenies und
sie alle vermissen ihre kinder sehr
diesen schmerzen immer mit tausende
fragezeichen schlimmer aus für
eigentlich nie wirklich niculescu baron
ist gerade mit seiner frau aus rumänien
zurück gekommen
sie vermissen ihren sohn willi sehr
sechs monate ohne sascha schmittel 6
bronze dass ich mit dem es gibt ohne
worte die angehörigen treffen sich auch
immer wieder in der begegnungsstätte
neunzehnter februar um zu reden und zu
trauern dem ist kürbis und ihr mann
haben ihren sohn set verloren
er wurde in seiner shisha bar erschossen
unserer schmerz ist unerträglich tag zu
tag mehr und ich möchte gerne meinen
sohn wieder zurück haben mein ich habe
ihn sehr viel
also beschäftigt und natürlich warum
wieso wir wollen gerne antwort haben in
die begegnungsstätte der initiative
neunzehnter februar kommt auch
regelmäßig mir salam haschemi er und
seine familie haben am 19 februar ihren
sohn und bruder zeit nicht verloren und
sie mussten um ein anderes kind bahnen
mirza lahms sohn ist es wurde schwer
verletzt gegen die schulter
den hans aber auch getroffen hat ganz
schlafen ganze nacht
also laufen seien ganze wohnung
wir schlafen auch nicht und das war
unserer erleben und die kleiner kinder
fragt uns immer wir können nicht das
antwort geben das uns sehr schwierig
auch sein sohn zeitmesser hätte
vielleicht überleben können wenn der
notausgang in der arena bar offen
gewesen wäre
sein vater fordert klarheit die polizei
alle ermittler sollten ihre arbeit
machen so lang dass mara und das ist
unser wunsch und wir haben unsere kinder
verloren
philipp gohmann der vater von mercedes
kippt stellt sich auch viele fragen vor
allem versteht er nicht warum der täter
tobias er unbehelligt blieb obwohl er
seine radikalen rassistischen
botschaften sogar noch kurz vor der tat
im internet geäußert hatte auslösender
das der ideale aus dem waffenschein
verlängert rassistisch gewaltbereit und
trotzdem legaler waffenbesitzer eine
gefährliche kombination tobias er hatte
seine morde geplant mögliche tatorte in
hanau mehrfach ausspioniert wettbüros
bars cafés er wollte da zuschlagen wo
viele menschen zusammen kam
die für den rassisten tobias er keine
deutschen waren
der 43 jährige war 2002 der psychiatrie
und später mitglied in zwei
schützenvereinen in münchen und bergen
enkheim 2013 stellte tobias er bei der
waffenbehörde seinen ersten antrag für
eine waffenbesitzkarte
eine rückfrage beim gesundheitsamt ob
psychische erkrankungen vorliegen fand
nicht statt
und muss auch bis heute nicht erfolgen
das hessische innenministerium sieht
keine fehler
eine rechtsgrundlage für eine
regelanfrage der waffenbehörden bei den
gesundheitsämtern kann nur durch den
bundesgesetzgeber im waffengesetz
verankert werden
und vom bundesinnenministerium heißt es
dazu
zur verbesserung des
informationsaustauschs der
waffenbehörden mit den gesundheitsämtern
hat das bmi für die 213 konferenz der
innenminister handlungsempfehlungen
unterbreitet einen konkreten zeitplan
gibt es derzeit noch nicht fest steht es
gibt bis heute keine regelung für eine
verpflichtende zuverlässigkeitsprüfung
durch die waffenbehörden ein
psychiatrisches oder psychologisches
gutachten verlangt das gesetz nur von
bewerbern bis 25 jahre eine wohl kaum
nachvollziehbare altersgrenze tobias er
war 43 jahre alt der brust duman von der
initiative neunzehnter februar kann
nicht verstehen dass jemand wie tobias
er weder in den fokus des
verfassungsschutzes noch der ermittler
geriet wenn der anzeige beim
generalbundesanwaltschaft angeht wo
drinsteht das ist die finale anzeige und
der auf seine website hinweist da müssen
doch die behörden zumindest zwei minuten
lang dieser recherche machen auf die
webseite gehen das ist ja nicht mal
versteckt sondern er hat sich ja selbst
gemeldet quasi die hätten einfach nur
danach kommen müssen
und die haben es nicht gemacht die haben
es nicht gemacht weil sie es nicht für
so relevant hielten weil sie es nicht
für wichtig hielten
und dieses nicht danach gucken hat am
ende neun jungen menschen das leben
gekostet
[Musik]
und wir haben die ganze monate in gefahr
gelebt auch der vater von tobias er
verschickt derzeit wäre anzeigen und die
angehörigen der opfer haben angst und
sind wütend
ende dezember demonstrierten sie in der
nähe des hauses wo tobias er wohnte und
sein vater bis heute lebt von seinen
anzeigen bei der polizei haben sie nur
durch presseberichte erfahren
und jetzt sollen sie auch noch die
gefährlichen sein nachdem der vater aus
der psychiatrischen behandlung damals
entlassung wurde bekam wierig die
überlebenden die angehörigen gefährden
ansprachen
wir sollen uns der vater doch ja nicht
mehr in
ansonsten habe das schwere konsequenzen
für uns jetzt frage ich mich wer hier in
deutschland eigentlich wenig warum haben
wir keine gefährdeten ansprache bekommen
seit april schreibt der vater des täters
an behörden erfordert die waffen zurück
er sieht seinen sohn als opfer und für
die wiedergutmachung sagen noch mehrere
menschenleben erforderlich wann will die
polizei was dagegen tun
der vater von tobias er hatte in seinen
anzeigen auch gefordert die
gedenkstätten für die opfer vom 19
februar abzuschaffen weil das
volksverhetzung sei unter dem controller
halten mindestens finde ich ist immer
nur genau wie sein sohn krank sie sich
krank und warum wird immer noch im
gleichen haus und warum er ist ja immer
noch in unseren nachbarn ja jetzt was
wir hier machen soll normalerweise
behörde machen
wer macht was keiner macht was
fühlen was sollen wir noch warten was
sollen wir noch warten nächsten anschlag
ich denke mal die nächste ausrede wäre
ja wir hätten es auch nicht gewusst aber
nichts gewusst
ihr habt es ganz deutlich gewusst ihr
seht und immer trotzdem nichts
hans-gerd er der vater des terroristen
kamen während der demonstration aus
seinem haus und beschwerte sich darüber
bei der polizei danach erstattete er
wieder anzeige diesmal gegen teilnehmer
der demonstration
wörtlich heißt es die gruppe der wilden
fremden solle das maul halten und sich
dem deutschen volk und dem grundgesetz
vom 23 mai 1949 unterordnen
deswegen hat die staatsanwaltschaft
anklage gegen hans gerd er erhoben wegen
beleidigung
doch viele fragen sich kannte der vater
von tobias er die tat pläne seines
sohnes hat er ihn sogar unterstützt der
73 jährige hatte ausgesagt in der
tatnacht um 20 uhr ins bett gegangen zu
sein und bis 24 uhr geschlafen zu haben
blaulicht habe ihn geweckt doch es gibt
zwei nachbarinnen die ausgesagt haben
ihn jeweils um 22 30 und etwa 23.30
draußen gesehen zu haben
eine habe sich gewundert weil hans gerd
er hinter dem haus zu den parkplätzen
gegangen sei ein umweg
er sei dann zum auto seines sohnes
gelaufen
sie hat dann festgestellt dass der vater
offen sich in das auto rein geleuchtet
hat dass er womöglich dort irgendwas
gesucht hat in das auto des sohnes
wir gehen davon aus weil ja die ceska
die eine mordwaffe in dem auto
verblieben ist dass er danach gesucht
hatte
auch das setzt voraus dass er mit seinem
sohn in der ganzen zeit schon
kommuniziert hat dass die darüber
geredet haben was da los war in der
nacht gibt es eine mindestens beihilfe
der sonstige beihilfe bei diesen taten
die kurz davor passiert sind
nach wurden nicht richtig danach wurde
bislang kaum ermittelt und wieder sind
es die angehörigen die jetzt anzeige
erstattet haben gegen hans gerd er wegen
beihilfe zum mord anfang februar lud der
hessische landtag zu einem gedenken an
die opfer von hanno 1
[Musik]
das attentat von hanau ist die
eskalation rassistischen
rechtsextremistisch motivierter
anschläge in deutschland in jüngster
zeit und ich hatte das damals kurz nach
dem attentat gesagt und ich sage das
auch heute wieder
ich empfinde zorn aber ich empfinde auch
charme
nichts gekommen an diesem tag nach
wiesbaden ist rts um war die mutter von
fährt hat sagt dass sie es satt habe das
immer nur geredet und nicht gehandelt
wurde
im namen von fährt hat hat sie vor
kurzem ein projekt ins leben gerufen mit
dem sie gegen rassismus an den schulen
formieren will auch fährt hat habe
rassismus durch lehrer erlebt die haben
ihm nicht akzeptieren der war
hochbegabten steht ja alles im papier
141 arco hat er gehabt
manche länder haben ihm nicht gemacht
und das kind hat anfang natürlich zu mir
gesagt aber das habe ich so lienen
gesagt jetzt schutz immer noch bei mir
weg ist ja so hier ist deutschland ist
nicht deutsch
die lieben dich nicht aber trotzdem
borussia weitermachen
auch der bürgermeister von hanau kam als
happy themis unwahr ihr projekt
offiziell in einer schule vorstellte
claus kaminsky zeigt sich beeindruckt
von ihrer stärke und insgesamt
nachdenklich ein jahr nach dem
rassistischen terror in seiner stadt die
tatsache dass die familien und und in
der folge die mädchen bisher erkennbar
deutlich deutlich mehr zur aufklärung
beigetragen haben
dies erschütternd
weil das ist nicht nur bitter sondern
das zerstört auch vertrauen
ein jahr ist vergangen seitdem hanau
neun menschen getötet wurden nur weil
sie keine deutschen wurzeln hatten
die angehörigen fragen sich heute mehr
denn je ob die morde hätten verhindert
werden können wenn polizei
ermittlungsbehörden und
verfassungsschutz besser gearbeitet
hätten
sie fordern eine lückenlose aufklärung
warum diese jungen menschen sterben
mussten
[Musik]